la sorcellerie la magie c'est pareil
alors dans le chudon je mets toutes mes
produits magiques je fais mes potions
dedans des sorcières il y en a encore
des vrais en France on en parle parfois
dans des villages isolés du Berry ou de
la Creuse et bien Corine mag etant en
ont rencontré une à hier dans le Var
elle s'appelle Carmen et c'est une vraie
sorcière du haut de ce chîn 1000 ans de
sorcellerie nous contemple forêt magique
du Pays Varois où les esprits se
promènent où sorcières et
apprentissorciers font la cuueillette où
la croyance en Dieu à ses miracles et à
ses seints engendre la croyance au
diable à ses artifices et aux sorciers
c'est un visage découvert que Carmen la
sorcière du varard témoigne aujourd'hui
c'est aux yeux de tous qu'elle dévoile
le secret de ses incantations je peux
bien sûr faire du mal comme je peux
faire du bien hein quand on est sorcière
on fait les deux mais moi j'adore faire
du bien j'aime beaucoup dans la petite
ville de hier les pouvoirs de Carmen ne
font aucun
[Musique]
doute m carabos mi sorcière bien-aimée
elle est redouté et respecter de tous et
nombreux sont ceux qui viennent lui
commander des travaux
occultes vous êtes
[Musique]
Unis
moi qui tiens le pouvoir des pouvoirs et
la force suprême je vous donne ordre de
quitter ces lieux et d'accomplir ma
volonté et mes ordres tels que je vous
les ai dicté et commandé nous avons la
chance d'avoir Carmen dans dans notre
région c'est une des dernières sorcières
qui reste elle pratique son travail
d'une manière remarquable et c'est vrai
que je ne prends jamais aucune décision
surtout professionnelle sans la vi vi de
CARM elle pratique des rituels sur de
vieux grimoir elle elle utilise des
herbes elle utilise toute la panoplie de
de sorcellerie le
petit je demande la délégation des de
taper plus fort la délégation plus fort
la sorcellerie la magie c'est pareil
alors dans le Chaudon je mets toutes mes
mes produits magiqu je fais mes potions
dedans donc les herbes les huiles donc
bien sûr comme dans le temps il faisait
on mettait les CPAU on mettait des des
serpents qu'on met dedans donc c'est les
produits de la
[Musique]
sorcellerie que l'on évoque Satan ou que
l'on invoque l'ange Gabriel vous l'aurez
compris la sorcellerie n'est pas un jeu
d'enfant nous avons on voulu poser une
dernière question à Carmen en ces termes
dans la sorcellerie n'y a-t-il pas un
peu de fiction et beaucoup de cinéma la
réponse est venue d'un coup de baguette
magique
redoutable fois de crapaau maintenant
moi j'y
[Musique]
crois